what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today on a series
of conversations with a feminist i'm
pearl and i'm the feminist um today
we're going to be reacting to jordan
peterson's
kathy newman
tell the people where they can find you
um you can find me on my new youtube
it'll be in the description it is called
um life with raw you know what you're
gonna put on there
not yet not yet okay she might do some
like behind the scenes stuff right
yeah maybe some like lifestyle videos um
maybe some opinions yeah help her out
hit that subscribe button and hit the
subscribe button for my channel okay if
you've watched two or more more of my
videos we have
beef okay
it's not cool it's free
okay so
jordan peterson let's go
so just a little preface he is a social
psychologist
and you're gonna i quote him a lot so
you're gonna notice a lot of things i
say on the show like he talks about
you ready
jordan peterson you've said that men
need to quote grow the hell up tell me
why
well because there's nothing
uglier than an old infant
there's nothing good about it
people who don't grow up don't find the
sort of meaning in their life that
sustains them through difficult times
and they're certain to encounter
difficult times
and they're left bitter and resentful
and without purpose and adrift and
hostile and resentful and vengeful and
arrogant and deceitful and and of no use
to themselves and of no use to anyone
else and no partner for a woman and
there's nothing in it that's good so you
say i mean that sounds pretty bad you're
saying the crisis of masculinity i mean
what do you do about it
you
tell
you help people understand why
it's necessary and important for them to
grow up and adopt responsibility why
that isn't uh shake your finger and get
your act together sort of thing why it's
more like
why it's more like
a delineation of the kind of destiny
that makes life worth living i've been
telling young men and but it's not i
wasn't specifically aiming this message
at young men to begin with it just kind
of turned out that way and it's mostly
you admit it's mostly men listening i
mean it is your audience well it's about
80 on in on youtube which is a
youtube is a male domain primarily so
it's hard to tell how much of it is
because youtube is male and how how much
of it is because of what i'm saying
but um
you you what i've been telling young men
is that there's an actual reason why
they need to grow up which is that they
have something to offer you know that
that
that people have within them this
capacity to set the world straight and
that's necessary to manifest in the
world and that also doing so is where
you find the meaning that sustains you
in life so what's gone wrong then
oh god all sorts of things have gone
wrong i think that
i don't think that young men are
hear words of encouragement some some of
them never in their entire lives as far
as i can tell that's what they tell me
and the fact that the words that i've
been that i've been speaking the youtube
lectures that i've done and put online
for example have had such a dramatic
impact is an indication that
young men are starving for this sort of
message because like why in the world
would they have to derive it from a
lecture on youtube now they're not being
taught that they that it's important to
develop yourself but does it does it
bother you that your audience is
predominantly
male does that isn't isn't that a bit
divisive no i don't think so i mean it's
no more divisive than the fact that
youtube is primarily male and tumblers
female isn't it tumblr is primarily
female
but you're just saying that's the way it
is well it's i'm not saying anything
it's just an observation that that's the
way it is um there's plenty of women
that are watching my lectures and coming
to my talks and buying my books it's
just that the majority of them happen to
be men
uh it's what's in it for the women
though
well what sort of partner do you want
you want an overgrown child
or do you want someone to contend with
that's going to help you do your rely on
women have some sort of duty to sort of
help fix the crisis of masculinity it
depends on what they want
no i mean it's it's exactly exactly how
i laid it out like
women want
deeply want men who are competent and
powerful
and and i don't mean power in in
in them in that they can exert
tyrannical control over others that's
not power that's just corruption
power is competence
and
why in the world would you not want a
competent partner well i i know why
actually you think so far
yeah i am agreeing with what he's saying
but i'm just a bit confused about what
she's trying to get at because i don't
think he's saying like just based off of
like
what we've heard so far i haven't seen
anything where he's saying like it's a
woman's responsibility like he's just
saying like
his audience is on youtube and youtube
is mill usually she's like well why like
she's like fishing she's like trying to
yeah so it's like certain way everything
i don't i don't see
what her argument is or it's like
i feel like there's something before
this that maybe we might be missing but
otherwise like i'm on his side because
what are what like i'm just confused
about what she's getting at so actually
i will give you a little backstory of
why the left really hates him like they
they hate jordan peterson
because he
he's a professor in canada
and what happened was
there was a law that said you have to
refer to trans people by their pronouns
okay
and he said i won't let the government
tell me what to say
so he didn't say he wouldn't he said if
he had a student like he and they asked
him to call him by their pronoun he
would do it but the problem is like like
you know what in the us it's about
freedom of speech and so he was saying
like you it's a slippery slope having
the government say you must say those
words
and so he was opposing that law and then
the left just made it seem like he was
this big
transphobe and all this stuff but is
that what is like relating to this video
no no but that's just why they hate him
so that's like maybe no he went there on
this interview to talk about his book
that's like a self-help book that mostly
men by
or like that mostly his audience is men
so i don't know why she was brain
like i just think they don't like him
because of that and they just see him a
certain way
i honestly haven't seen any bad videos
about him
this was a couple years ago
like nothing that there isn't but i
haven't seen anything like that he said
like that i've seen or like
i i know someone that like absolutely
watches him
so it's like
yeah but i i don't disagree with
anything that he's saying for right now
okay you can't dominate a competent
partner so if you want to dominate you
should dominate is that what you're
saying no i'd say women who have had
their relationships impaired with
impaired
their relationships with men
impaired and who are afraid of such
relationships will settle for a weak
partner because they can dominate them
but it's a sub-optimal solution do you
think there's not a lot of women
i think there's a substantial minority
of women who do that and i think it's
very bad for them they're very unhappy
it's very bad for their partners
although their partners get the
advantage of not having to take any
responsibility but what gives you the
right to say that i mean maybe that's
how women want their relationships those
women i mean you're making these vast
generalizations
she's a clinical psychologist
yeah okay
yeah right so you're saying you've done
your research and women are unhappy
dominating men
i didn't say they were unhappy
dominating men i said it was a bad
long-term solution okay you said it was
making them miserable yes it is and it
depends on the time frame i mean there
can be there's intense pleasure in
momentary domination that's why people
do it all the time but it's no formula
for a long-term successful long-term
relationship that's reciprocal right any
long-term relationship is reciprocal
virtually by definition
so
let me put a quote to you from the book
where you say there are whole
disciplines in universities forthrightly
hostile towards men these are the areas
of study dominated by the post-modern
stroke neo-marxist claim that western
culture in particular is an oppressive
structure created by white men to
dominate and exclude women
but then i want to put minorities too
dominating okay
but i want to put to you that here in
the uk for example let's take that as an
example the gender pay gap stands at
just over nine percent
you've got women at the bbc recently
saying that the broadcaster is illegally
paying them less than men to do the same
job you've got only seven women
running the top ftse 100 companies
so it seems to a lot of women that
they're still being dominated and
excluded to quote your words back to you
it does seem that way but multivariate
analysis of the pay gap indicate that it
doesn't exist
but that's just true is it i mean that's
nine percent kept pay gap that's a gap
between median hourly earnings between
men and women that exist yeah but
there's multiple reasons for that one of
them is gender but it's not the only
reason like if you're a social scientist
worth worth your salt you never do a
univariate analysis
like you say well women
in aggregate are paid less than men okay
well then we break it down by age we
break it down by occupation we break it
down by interest we break it down by
personality but you're saying basically
it doesn't matter if women aren't
getting to the top because that's what's
skewing that gender pay gap isn't it
you're saying well that's just a fact no
no no no no no
you're going to get to the top no i'm
not saying it doesn't matter either
you're saying there are multiple reasons
for it yeah but there's a reason why why
should women put up with those reasons
why should women be content i'm not
saying that they should put up with it
i'm saying that the claim that the wage
gap between men and women is only due to
sex is wrong and it is wrong there's no
doubt about that the multivariate
analysis have been done
multivariate analysis
i'm saying that nine percent pay gap
exists that's a gap between men and
women i'm not saying why it exists but
it exists now if you're a woman that
seems pretty unfair
you have to say why it exists but do you
agree that it's unfair if you're a woman
not necessarily and on average you're
getting paid 9 less than a man that's
not fair is it
it depends on why it's happening
i can give you an example
okay
there's a personality trait known as
agreeableness
agreeable people are compassionate and
polite
and agreeable people get paid less than
just didn't less agreeable people for
the same job
women are more agreeable than men
again a vast generalization
that's true but that's right and some
women get paid more than men so you were
saying that by and large women are too
agreeable to get the pay rises now i'm
saying that that's one component of a
multivariate equation that predicts
um salary
it accounts for maybe five percent of
the variance something like that so if
you need about another twenty about
another eighteen factors one of which is
gender and there is prejudice there's no
doubt about that but it accounts for a
much smaller proportion of the variance
in the pay gap than the radical
feminists claim okay so rather than
denying the pay gap exists which is what
you did at the beginning of this
conversation shouldn't you say to women
rather than being agreeable and not
asking for a pay rise go and ask for a
pay right make yourself disagreeable
with your boss oh definitely there's
that but i also didn't deny it existed i
denied it it existed because of gender
okay because i'm very very very
careful with my words
so the pay gap exists you accept that
but you're saying
i mean the pay gap between men and women
exists but you're saying it's not
because of gender it's because women are
too agreeable to ask for pay rises so
one of the reasons okay one of the
reasons so why not get them to ask for a
pay raise i've done that
many many times in my career and they
just counseled oh they do it all the
time you can it's so one of the things
that you do as a clinical psychologist
is um assertiveness training so you
might say
often you treat people for anxiety you
treat them for depression um and you and
maybe the next most common category
after that would be assertiveness
training and so i've had many many women
extraordinarily competent women in my
clinical and consulting practice and we
put together strategies for their career
development that involve continual
pushing competing for higher wages and
often tripled their wages within a
five-year period
you celebrate
of course so
do you actually do you agree that you
would be happy if that pay gap was
eliminated completely what do you think
well i uh you know what we talked about
the other day yeah um i can kind of see
that like saying to take account for the
other factors not just like
that it's just because they're a male or
just because they're a woman or whatever
but um
those different factors
that's like although like you may not
like it yeah it's just like
it's and then also like i do think that
we are agreeable because even like i
i like ask for a raise and i i set my
intentions of like
um
saying a certain price
and
like it was a price like even that price
i feel like it was like the generous
price that i was like asking you to move
to and then
i
i didn't get what i wanted but i didn't
get a erase but not what i wanted like
it was under that and it was only
because i just took it instead of like
saying no like i deserve to get more
than this so i think that is like the
thing but also i feel like
when you're considering these things
like
i feel like some people may not be at
liberty to to really fight for their
race because you know like they're
depending on their job so they can't
they can't be like no i need more money
because i deserve more money and then
they're fired now they don't have any
job
well disagreeable people find other like
they just say well screw it i'm not
dealing with this i'm gonna go find
another job
you know what i mean yeah but do you
like i i don't i do get that but i'm
saying i don't think it's like some
people don't have that ability to like
like
because
some like some people cannot quit their
job
because they have to like they're
working like to survive or is that that
kind of thing they choose not to and
yeah anyone can quit their job it's just
like some people are more risk-averse
yeah obviously yeah yeah obviously
anyone can quit like anyone can do
anything like for that argument yeah the
point of the matter is they can't
because some people have more to lose
yeah that's what i'm saying but like it
also it depends on being risk-averse so
i'll give you an example i have four
brothers okay wait i have five brothers
i have five brothers and i could tell
you my i have one brother that will make
the most money out of all of them if
if any of them was gonna get rich i
could tell you which brother is gonna be
because
that brother would put
all of his money into something that
could fail
you know what i'm saying like like and
so some people don't want to take the
risk of quitting their job to find
another
you know what i mean yeah definitely but
like some people are just like [ __ ]
i'll figure it out
what do you think of her
um
she's fine i think she just like
wants the best for a woman
okay
can you turn the captions on
yes okay but i think also like her um
it's one of those things
like say i i've looked i i've taken my
like my feelings or whatever and i'm
like i'm willing to live from other
perspectives
yeah i see the doctors can account and
it's like
her feelings are so into it like nothing
gets wrong but i feel like her feelings
are more into it like it's like a
personal attack on her like no woman
shouldn't be but he's because he even
said
it could be like multiple things and
it's not because of
like he even mentioned about like race
that like the
racial pay gap not just
sex pay gap
so well it's interesting because i
i just think he knows more than her
about this this is what he's done for
like 20 30 years and instead of taking a
step back and like listening to what he
has to say
it just it annoys me when people that
are doing nothing
are attacking the people doing something
like he he literally works with women to
help them get right like this is the guy
we want on our team he's helping us get
like the outcomes we want and she's just
going in on him as if he's the enemy
because he acknowledges like because he
studies this stuff you know what i mean
you agree disagree
now i hear what you think yeah you would
be happy
if that pay gap was eliminated
completely because that's all the
radical feminists are saying it would
depend on how it was eradicated and how
the how how the disappearance of it was
measured
and you're saying if it's at the cost of
men that's a problem oh there's all
sorts of things that it could be at the
cost of it could even be at the cost of
women's own interests
so because they might not be happy if
they get equal pay
no because it might interfere with other
things that are causing the pay gap that
women are choosing to do like having
children
well or choosing careers that actually
happen to be paid less which women do a
lot of but why shouldn't women have the
right to choose not to have children or
the right to choose those demands i
think the difference is like
when people are saying about pay gap no
one is saying
i don't think the argument is that i'm
being paid less than a doctor like
obviously
i think the argument is within the same
career so
you're a person a i'm person b and we're
doing the same exact thing like same
everything like nothing is different
and you're getting paid more i think
that's argument not oh
you choose a bad career no one is saying
like i don't i legitimately don't think
that like because that that is another
issue of like
this i'm in a low-paying job
the reason the reason that they bring it
up like that is because uh
have you heard this stat like 75 cents
to the dollar
of what like like whether the pay gap is
like like women make 75 cents to the
dollar
i probably have seen something like that
so the reason he's bringing that up is
because that's the step feminists use
and the way they take that stat is they
take the what women make and what men
make without taking into account any of
the variables and so they lead women to
believe that there's a bigger pay gap
than there is and to me it's very
dishonest because they don't take into
account things like the doctor and the
nurse
yeah like i just i just think it is only
right if you're comparing
like the same like i'm in a sales
accountant yeah and you're a sales
accountant and we're both doing the same
exact thing like that you can compare
that but there's no way in hell that
you're comparing like ceo to manager or
like the different titles and stuff like
it's just not sensible but i agree and
this is why like i don't believe in
feminism because they promote no i i
seriously don't believe in it at all
because i think it's so dishonest like
they they chanted that stat and would
lead women to believe we're getting paid
like 75 cents to the dollar and it's
just dishonest
and i'm like and the people in charge
i'm like there's no way they don't know
this like they have to know
and so to me i'm like why are you like
why do you want women to feel like
there's a bigger pay gap than there is
that doesn't make sense
what do you think about um
have you have you seen where
uh different companies have uh
like been trying to say like you cannot
disclose to your
co-workers
how much you're making and then like
they'll just be like [ __ ] you no we're
still gonna say yeah and they're telling
like they're telling x y and z
and then they actually like see like
this like vast difference between like
all the different people and like
they're just all willing because like
you're you're my co-worker and like i i
think you should be equally paid to
speak like we're doing the same thing
and it's like you're getting two dollars
more than me uh-huh and so like they're
all so how do you feel about that when
like multiple people are
like are breaking that are you saying or
yeah like more or less for the same job
yeah yeah well okay so
if i'm an employer right i may i may
have the money to pay someone between 40
and 65. and then especially like if
you're saying like um
don't disclose like you're telling
yourself don't disclose like i think
okay i think if i have my own company i
have a right to make whatever rule i
want okay like i'm starting a business
if i want to make better rule i will i
won't but like if i wanted to i could
you know what i'm saying like i don't
think i have a right to do what i want
in my own business and if you don't like
it don't work for me
that's that's how i feel but but i don't
think that's like that the thing is when
a company is hiring someone they might
have a budget between 40 and 60 000
so the way the company makes the most
money
is by getting you to do the most work as
possible for the least amount of money
does that make sense yeah so let's say
so if i can get you to agree to 40
that's like a win for me that's what
they say to always negotiate your first
salary because you're always gonna be
building off of that
so like at my old job i made like five
grand more than all my co-workers
and it was just because i told them i
had a competing offer if you want me
this is what it is
yeah they lie about it no i actually did
i really did um
but
like i i don't think it's wrong for a
company to try to get the best deal they
can get
the same way i don't think it's wrong
for someone working to try to get the
most money they can get
like so some people in the same job make
different amounts of money i think it's
your job to figure out how to negotiate
better
so you don't think it is on on the
employer to not explain people but
rather is your your is solely your job
to
vocalize like 100 vocalized rather
saying you know you actually shouldn't
be exploiting people and you should just
pay them
what they're worth well i don't it's not
exploiting people because you're only
worth what you can get
i could say i'm worth a hundred thousand
dollars but if i can't get anyone to pay
me a hundred thousand dollars i'm not
worth that
so it's not exploiting someone if
they're openly agreeing to something
just because it is it is innocence
because if you
if you know that you like
if you should be paying me at a certain
price but you can get away with paying
me way less
i feel like that is still exploiting not
really because okay again if the
budget's between forty and sixty
thousand dollars let's say i have for
someone why would i wanna use my entire
budget
because if if you get a profit then i
can reinvest that into the business
and like it's better to compete with
competitors it's better for businesses
if they can get you to do more work for
less money i guess the final thing is
negotiate and then leave if they're not
paying you whatever you're wanting are
you gonna do it
with your job
yeah i think i think whenever i do get a
job like because yeah i don't have a job
um oh i thought you still were just
asking for a raise no no this was like
the last stop oh i've never really
worked in my life you've never worked
like i like i've i have not saying it
like that like
i've had
two
two actual jobs but most of the time it
was like volunteering like i'm only 21.
okay so like
it wasn't until
like coveted i moved back home and then
i was working that was a disaster and
then i moved
i
went to another job oh okay yeah
they do
was having weak partners
that makes them miserable but um i would
say that many women around the age of i
would say between 28 and 32 have a
career family crisis that they have to
deal with and i think that's partly
because of the foreshortened time frame
that women have to contend with like
women have to
get the major pieces of their life put
together faster than men which is also
part of why men aren't under so much
pressure to grow up so because for the
typical woman um
she has to have her career family in
order
pretty much by the time she's 35.
because otherwise the options start to
run out and so that puts a tremendous
amount of stress on women especially at
the end
with
of
their
of the typical woman because you know
all women are different
another quote to you from the book today
in some ways and the same in others
okay you say women become more
vulnerable when they have children
you talk to one of your youtube
interviews about crazy happy sisters
so
a simple question
is gender equality a myth in your view
is that something that's just never
going to happen
it depends what you mean by equality
where people were treated fairly or more
fairly i mean people are treated pretty
fairly in western culture already but
they're really not though are they
otherwise why would there only be seven
women running for 100 companies in the
uk why why would there still be a pay
gap which we've discussed
why are women at the ptc saying that
they're getting paid illegally less than
men to do the same thing that's not fair
let's go to the first question they're
both complicated questions seven seven
women
seven women running the top 400
companies in the uk
the first question might be
who are perfectly willing to sacrifice
virtually all of their life to the
pursuit of a high-end career so they'll
work these are men that are very
intelligent they're usually very very
conscientious they're very driven
they're very high energy they're very
healthy and they're willing to work 70
or 80 hours a week non-stop specialized
at one thing to get to the talk so
usually women are just more sensible
they don't want that
i'm saying that's part of it definitely
and so i worry
you don't think there are barriers in
their way that prevent them getting to
the topic
i mean to get to the top of any
organization is an incredibly
competitive enterprise and the men that
you're competing with are simply not
going to roll over and say please take
the positions
gender equality a myth
i don't know what you mean by the
question men and women aren't the same
and they won't be the same that doesn't
mean they can't be treated fairly is
gender equality desirable
if it means equality of outcome then
almost certainly it's undesirable that's
already been demonstrated in scandinavia
because in scandinavian
equality
is undesirable well men and women won't
sort themselves into the same categories
if you leave them alone to do it off
their own accord first scandinavia
female nurses to male something like
that it might not be quite that extreme
and approximately the same male
engineers to female engineers and that's
a consequence of the free choice of men
and women in the societies that have
gone farther than any other societies to
make gender equality the purpose of the
law those are interactive differences
you can eradicate them with tremendous
social pressure and tyranny but if you
leave men and women to make their own
choices you will not get any blood right
so you're saying that anyone who
believes in equality whether you call
them feminist school whatever you want
to call them should basically give up
because it ain't going to happen only if
they're aiming at equality
so you're saying give people equality
of opportunity that's fine it's not only
fine it's eminently desirable for
everyone for individuals and for society
but still women aren't going to make it
that's what you're really saying
techniques they're doing just fine in
medicine in fact they're far more female
physicians than there are male
physicians
there are lots of lots of disciplines
that are absolutely dominated by women
many many disciplines and they're doing
great
so let me put something else to you
immediately complicates even salary
comparison beyond practicality for one
simple reason who decides what work is
equal it's not possible so the simple
question is do you believe in equal pay
uh
no i'm not saying that at all because a
lot of people listening to you will just
say i mean are we going back to the
are you are you listening kathy
what do you what do you think so far
i don't know i don't think she's
listening i think
i think it's her heart is too far in it
yeah i don't i think she's like putting
her i i think it's funny on both sides
like he's he's very like he's a bit
condescending he's like well actually i
don't know it depends
well no i didn't say that it depends
yeah well he's just he's very like
careful with what he says yeah
analytical what do you what do you think
about what he said about um
like women competing for the top
positions
i i'm i'm seeing his points about like
you know we don't actually want that
my dad i'm telling you i watched my dad
live his life he missed out on
everything
like i don't think most people would
sign up for that even i don't think most
men would sign up i don't think as women
we have the the right to to
miss out in life like we always have to
be present like especially like you know
if you are going to be a mom like you
know you're having to attend to this kid
whatever job you're working and at this
point if it's like this like higher job
it's probably not just like nine to five
you're probably gonna do something after
hours and then you're gonna have to like
cooking for this family
making your kid lunch um getting your
kids to bed getting your kid to school
making sure the kid did their homework
are they having a tutor like or what
extracurriculars are they doing or
whatever uh what are you doing outside
of work you know what is your relaxation
are you what what are you doing for
yourself and then like
yeah no i think when most women would
prefer to have like a work-life balance
more where they're not working like 80
90 hours a week yeah especially like the
cio or cfo ceo of like a multi like
billion dollar company right you're
never going to leave
you know how much work that is to run it
should be like like better distributed
so it's not just on one person like
i think so many systems fall short
because you're it's like reliant on on
one one factor or like one entity where
it should be split so and then also like
say i'm doing a job
you should equally know how to do the
job so that if i'm ever not there it's
not gonna be like
there's not gonna be anything missing
well i think the issue is competence
like the higher and higher up you go you
have to be more and more competent
and like there's certain when you get to
a certain level like there's just not a
lot of people that can like help you out
like i i'm i um i know someone that was
like
he was the head of
he had some weird job title but he was
really high up in like a bank or
something
and it was because he was a lawyer he
was an accountant and he was like one
like three professions that were very
random and so he got paid a [ __ ] ton of
money but he worked a lot because no one
else can do that job
who's a lawyer and an accountant
like not many people
does that make sense or not no i get it
but
like
if if more people can do that like it
should be split to where it's not just
him doing it like obviously like it's
working for him but
especially in america like we're just
like
because we're a work system like
everything's about working
um
and
there should be some kind of system to
counteract it just relying on one person
because realistically that's not good
because say if he dies tomorrow then
what are you gonna do pay someone a ton
of money to replace him yeah
granted but you're saying so like
no one is no one is as qualified to do
his job so if you're not training
someone or if there's no one else to
fill his shoes or whatever say he's
going tomorrow like
right now i understand what you're
saying but like from a company
perspective i don't think they want to
pay two people to do the same job so
they're not gonna they wouldn't be
working as much also
right but they'd still be paying two
salaries and those guys want a certain
amount of money they they have a right
to demand it so i don't think we should
be telling people how much they should
and shouldn't work like people can just
do what they want to do i think if the
opportunity was there because yeah
granted some people do want to work but
i think there should be an option
because a lot of people are working more
than they want to
no i'm telling not those guys i i know i
know so many guys just like my dad those
guys my dad's retired and he's still
working he just started another company
that's like
it's just like in them
it's their innate like they can't
they can't turn it off
there's just certain guys that
are crazy
sorry dad
watching this
so you don't want to leave an equal pay
no i'm not saying that at all because a
lot of people listening to you will just
say i mean are we going back to the
doctor they're actually not listening
i'm just being projected
you basically saying women need to just
accept they're never going to make it on
equal terms equal outcomes is what how
you defined it no idea if i was a young
woman watching that i would go well i
might as well just go and play with my
cindy dolls i'd give up trying at school
because i'm not going to get the top job
i want because there's someone sitting
there saying it's not possible
desirable that's what i said it's a it's
a bad social goal i didn't say that
women do you understand what he when he
says equal outcomes aren't desirable
what he's saying yeah like say
it's it's one of those things you want
it until you realize you have it and you
don't actually want it
well this is you remember last video
when i was saying that equality like any
group it's never going to be equal like
there's always going to be differences
because people in different groups
choose different things
so like for example i would guess if you
did a german subgroup in like the us
of like germans who immigrated i bet
they would be above average because a
lot of them are engineers
does that make sense
and so like a lot of times it's just
like a mindset thing like when you see a
disparity like
it's not good to just automatically
assume it's like one thing because
there's always multiple variables
does that make sense agree disagree yeah
that's fine that's fair oh i didn't say
that women shouldn't be striving for the
top or anything like that because i
don't believe that for a second striving
for the top but you're going to put all
those hurdles in their way as has been
in their way for centuries and that's
fine you're saying that's fine no no
cindy
he's not saying that i really the
patriarchal system is just that's silly
i do i think that's silly i really do i
mean look look at your situation you're
hardly unsuccessful yeah and i have how
do you make it hard to get exactly
good that's okay battling is good this
is all about inevitable but you talk
about men
let me just put another thing to you
from the bottom you're saying you have
to battle for a high quality position
well i notice in your book you talk
about real conversations between men
containing quote an underlying threat of
physicality oh there's no doubt about
that what about real conversations
between women is that something are we
sort of too amenable and reasonable
no it's just that
the domain of physical conflict is sort
of off limits for you well you just
i don't imagine that you've yeah to some
degree i suspect you're not very
agreeable so that's the thing success
for women i'm not very agreeable right
yeah i don't have that actually in this
conversation and i'm sure it served your
career well successful women though
basically have to wear the trousers in
your view they have to sort of become
men to succeed is what you're saying
well if they're i've had to fight to
succeed
against men certainly masculine traits
are going to be helpful i mean one of
the things i do
in in my counseling practice for example
when i'm consulting with women who are
trying to advance their careers is to
teach them how to negotiate and to and
to be able to say no and to not be
easily pushed around and to be
formidable and you need to if you're
going to be successful you need to be
smart conscientious and tough well
here's a radical idea why don't the
bosses adopt some the male bosses shall
we say adopt some female traits so that
women don't have to fight and get their
sharp elbows out for the pay rises it's
just accepted if they're doing the same
job they get the same pay
well i would say partly because it's not
so easy to determine what constitutes
the same job and almost because
arguably yeah there are still men
dominating our industries our society
and therefore they've dictated the term
i was gonna say this earlier
but also you don't know if someone has
the same job and maybe the same
responsibilities you don't know if one's
better than that better than the other
at it
i feel like you would know
well i feel like
a lot of people that aren't as good at
it might not admit it
say if you're working in a space where
you are able to see like what your
colleagues are doing like and compare
work i feel like you know and like say
like i've had
groups of people that i've worked with
or
yeah girls who i've worked with and it's
like i know that i'm i'm actually like
doing better than whatever you're doing
like you're not doing [ __ ] um
but we're in the same place yeah
no i
i agree but that's why like sometimes
i'm saying at face value you might think
oh they're in the same job one's getting
paid more one's getting paid less but
you also don't know how many hours
they're putting in and you also don't
know if one's more competent than the
other
yeah but i think it just should not be
compared on like
say per hour like as best as you can to
put it as a per hour think rather than
oh i'm getting paid because obviously if
you're working if i'm working five and
you're working two hours obviously i'm
going to have more money because i've
worked a longer time but the majority
like a full-time jobs are salaries
it's not per hour in the u.s yeah but
i'm saying like it
that would be the only thing like say
even if you divided the salary based on
like
calculate it to where you could
have like compare based off of an hourly
thing or like how much someone's working
well i'm sure there's like a part of
that that happens so like if me and you
are the same job right same
responsibilities and let's say in a year
i put in 10 hours you put an eight a day
right and so at the end of the year i'm
much better at the job than you same job
same responsibilities i'm just better at
it by the end of the year they'll
probably give me a raise and they'll
probably they probably won't give you
one
so again on face value it would look
like oh they're in the same job one's
not being paid the same but one is just
better at it
and so that's why like again these
statistics that in my opinion like
feminism lies to people because they
always just assume a disparity is about
gender
when sometimes it's not like men work on
average more hours
i think they also have the ability to
yeah that's true i think men naturally
can like work longer hours than women
well i'm not saying that i'm saying
because women just have more
responsibility
i feel like women do like say i'm saying
like a mom has to be there like
but i think more women want that
responsibility though like i think women
it's just my this is just an opinion but
i think after a certain age like women
are like screw it my boss could fire me
tomorrow like i want to raise my kids
and i think we just have an innate
instinct like more than men do to be
with our children
i think outside of that instinct like
you just have to like
i've met a lot of guys that that seem to
be very willing
like i think if you ask most guys you
want to chill at the house
like if you if you know a bunch of men
that are just dying to work and take
care of you send them my way
i want to send them my way to
maybe lonely
um but i don't know i think some it's
like partially innate
i don't i don't think so like i feel
like dads are so lazy like even even if
they're they're like present in their
life like i feel like they do so much
less compared to a mom like i i
genuinely feel like that and like it
would be like oh do this
and this is
like time and time again it doesn't
matter like um
where they are in life like financially
like anything it's like
i just feel like dads are so [ __ ]
lazy oh my gosh no and i think they just
have the ability to i think that well
men work more hours
so like they they work longer hours they
make more money
so usually it's like the man's head you
would you would think so i think like
traditionally like
past time but now i don't i don't think
we do have a video game generation of
that i do think there is a large i don't
know so like they're just doing [ __ ]
or like oh i'm gonna hang out like and
say like i'm gonna hang out with my
friends and you take care of the kids no
no you come get these kids these are
your kids too that is not like where i
grew up that really wasn't
like that i would say most dads are
pretty involved in their kid's life
they can still be involved like even
[ __ ] they can be married to whoever and
they're still doing less or whatever
it's just
okay we'll continue the video there we
go
the terms for so long that women have to
battle to know that's not true
it's not true so for example
well i can give you an example very
quickly so i worked with women who
worked in high-powered law firms in
canada for about 15 years and they were
as
competent and put together as anybody
you would ever meet
and we were trying to figure out how to
further their careers
and there was a huge debate in canadian
society at that point that was basically
ran along the same lines as your
argument is that if the
law firms didn't use these masculine
criteria then perhaps women would do
better but the market sets the damn game
it's like and the market is dominated by
men no it's not it's not the market is
dominated by women they make 80 of the
consumer decisions that's not the case
at all you're talking about them people
who stay at home looking after children
by and large they are still women so
they're going out doing the shopping but
that is changing they make all of them
okay so market is driven by women not
men right okay and if you're a lawyer
they still pay more for the same sort of
goods
that's been proven that men for the you
buy a blue bicycle helmet it's going to
cost less than a pink one anyway we'll
come on to that partly because men are
less agreeable
right so so they won't put up with it i
want to ask you
is it not desirable to have some of
those female traits you're talking about
i'd say that's a generalization but
you've used the words female traits is
it not desirable to have some of them at
the top of business i mean maybe they
wouldn't they don't predict the banking
crisis they don't predict success in the
workplace the things that predict
success in the workplace are
intelligence and conscientiousness
agreeableness negatively predicts
success in the workplace
you're saying that women aren't
intelligent enough to run these top
companies no i didn't say that at all he
said that
female traits don't predict success but
i didn't say that intelligence wasn't i
didn't say that intelligence and
conscientiousness well you were saying
one two three female traits just by
implication are not female traits no no
i mean that's
not saying that at all are women less
intelligent than men no not no they're
not no the the data on that's pretty
clear the average iq for a woman in the
average iq for men is identical there is
some debate about the flatness of the
distribution which is something that
james de moore pointed out for example
in his memo but there's no difference at
all in general cognitive ability there's
no difference to speak of in
conscientiousness women are a bit more
orderly than men and men are a little
bit more industrious than women but the
difference isn't big i don't think that
averages into any men who aren't
necessarily well of course
why are they not feminine why are they
not desirable at the top of feminine
traits why are they not desirable at the
top it's hard to say i'm just laying out
the empirical evidence like we know that
we know the traits that predict success
but we also know because companies by
and large have not been dominated by
women over the centuries we have nothing
to compare it to
it's an experiment true and it could be
the case that if companies modified
their behavior and became more feminine
they would be successful but there's no
evidence for it i'm not neither doubtful
nor non-doubtful there's no evidence why
not give it a go as the radical the
evidence suggests well it's fine if like
if someone wants to start a company and
make it more feminine and compassionate
let's say and caring in its overall
orientation towards its workers and
towards the marketplace then that's a
perfectly reasonable experiment to run
my point is that there is no evidence
that those traits predict success in the
workplace and there's
been tried well that's not that's not
really the case women have been in the
workplace for what at least
ever since i've been around the
representation of women in the workplace
has been about 50 so we've run the
experiment for a fair fairly reasonable
period of time but not you know
certainly not for centuries let me move
on to another debate that's been very
controversial for you um
and this is you got in trouble for
refusing to call trans men and women by
their preferred personal pronoun what do
you think
what are you saying
i think it's it's fair it's like it it
hits me in the core yeah because it's
like
you can't i
honestly these things sound good but in
practice you cannot like you have to be
mean like in life you have to be mean
and you have to be selfish like that
that's just the way you're gonna get the
best results um
and i think like
as
uh
being female like like
as like as far as sex um
you're more like compassionate like we
we care like that's in our nature to
care more but it's like people it that's
not reality like other people don't care
so if we're like worried about like oh
pearl
oh but it's like you don't give a [ __ ]
about me like you're trying to stab me
and i'm just like oh like how can i help
it out and so it's like
i think that is true that that
that business will probably fall short
because you're not a stern or you're not
as serious so well and then okay so the
way he explained agreeableness and
disagreeableness he gave them an example
of firing somebody so let's say you're
disagreeable and i'm agreeable okay and
there's someone that's doing a bad job
the agreeable person is gonna think oh
no they might have a family at home
the disagreeable person is gonna think
this person's been doing a terrible job
he's been making it horrible for
everyone around him i can't wait to tell
him how bad he's been doing and get rid
of him
and which one is like better for the
company yeah obviously the meaner one
and it's like it doesn't have to be an
attack on the person but it's just like
you're not performing where i need you
to be so hit the road yeah but it just i
yeah that makes sense like as women like
we're not going to see it from that side
i hate it i have my manager i swear to
god i have my manager do all the hires
because i i i don't i don't like doing
it so if i like have like any higher i
run it through my manager because he's
cutthroat do you think you would so you
wouldn't be able to do it
i think i would be able i think i
wouldn't be good at it i like i think i
know where i'm what i'm good at i know
what i'm bad at and i know that is like
a weakness of mine so if i say yes if i
can have someone else do it i'd rather
like you be in charge of budget
does that make sense yeah onto another
debate that's been very controversial
for you
and this is you got in trouble for
refusing to call trans men and women by
their preferred personal pronouns
no that's not actually true i got in
trouble because i said i would not
follow the compelled speech dictates of
the federal and provincial government i
actually never got in trouble for not
calling anyone anything right that
didn't happen i wouldn't follow the
change of law which was designed not
once it was discriminated no no
that's all he said it was designed to do
okay you cited freedom of speech in that
why should your right to freedom of
speech
trump a trans person's right not to be
offended
because in order to be able to think you
have to risk being offensive i mean look
at the conversation we're having right
now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather uncomfortable
well i'm i'm very glad i put you on this
part
card
you get my point it's like you're you're
doing what you should do which is
digging a bit to see what the hell is
going on and that is what you should do
but you're exercising your freedom of
speech to certainly risk offending me
and that's fine i think more power to
you as far as i'm concerned
except you haven't sat there and
i'm just right i'm just trying to work
that out i mean
ha gotcha you have got me you have got
me i'm trying to work that through my
head yeah yeah it took a while took a
while
this guy is a joke
but she's been on in the whole interview
gotcha
oh my god she
you understood what he was saying though
right with the freedom of speech yeah
because he's
he he's his argument that now that he
wouldn't do it it's just like you have
no right to tell me if we're having free
speech yeah like you can't tell me what
words i can say
or not say like i can say what i want
[ __ ]
by the way kathy newman your pass
pass
i'll pass on both of them
are you passing
a voluntary
you have voluntarily come into this
studio and agreed to be questioned a
trans person in your class has come to
your class and said they want to be
called that's never happened
and i would call them she so you would
so you've kind of changed your channel
no no no i said that right from the
beginning what i said at the beginning
was that i was not going to cede the
linguistic territory to radical leftists
regardless of whether or not it was put
in law
that's what i said and then the people
who came after me said well you must be
transphobic and you'd mistreat a student
in your class it's like i never
mistreated a student in my class i'm not
transphobic and that isn't what i said
well except you've also called trans
campaigners authoritarian have you i
mean isn't that quite only in the
broader context of my claims that
radical leftist ideologues are
authoritarian which they are you're
saying someone who's trying to work out
their gender identity who may well have
struggled with that had quite a lot of
time struggles
you're comparing them with you know
chairman mao who no just sort of the
deaths of millions of people even
you know they're trans people too they
have a right to say these things yeah
but they don't have a right
their whole community compare them to
chairman mao
you know i could pinochet or gusto
punisher i mean you know this is grossly
insensitive i didn't compare them to
pinochet well i did compare an authority
he was an authoritarian he was a
right-winger though i was comparing them
to the left-wing totalitarians and i do
believe they are left-wing
do you understand what he's saying here
like the totalitarianism
you know that's it so basically what
he's saying is if you start saying to
people
i'm like this is what i'm waiting for no
yeah i do i didn't know who this mao is
yeah it's like these are i think
dictators i actually don't know who they
are either but yeah but i do understand
the totalitarian like government so yeah
okay
that actually would be quite bad and
it's
it's a bit mind-boggling thinking about
um
a lot like how a lot of things could be
implemented because it's just like it
will never happen and it can't ever
happen um
and say
yeah because
you're just gonna be controlling you're
going to have no freedom out like at
this point like
say
save for depression or to prevent
suicide and
now
you're there's a mandate and
each person has to be checked in on and
xyz to follow alongside but then at some
point
there's no there's no
like
there's no freedom for them because
oh no we have to make sure you're
fitting into these checks like you're
checking every box
and it's just crazy to think because
we'll never as much as we think we want
something it's not practical and that's
that's the problem with a lot of uh
concepts that we want there's no way to
implement them yeah it's like like yeah
yeah i think the idea is people
it might not be intentional like they
just want people to call them by their
preferred pronouns but like when you
have the government saying what you can
and cannot say like that's really
dangerous for a society because then the
government can tell you to say like oh
you can't talk that about the president
oh you can't say this it's like a
slippery slope and it all starts with
one policy
do you have any thoughts no no i think
it's the same thing yeah like okay
militarians under mao millions of people
died right i mean there's no comparison
but there's a mao and a trans activist
is there
why not
because trans activists aren't killing
millions of people
the philosophy that's guiding their
utterances is the same philosophy
the consequences are yet
you're saying that trans activists could
lead to the deaths of millions of people
no i'm saying that the philosophy that
drives their utterances is the same
philosophy that already has driven us to
the deaths of millions okay tell us how
that philosophy
is in any way comparable
sure that's no problem the first thing
is is that the philosophy presumes that
group identity is paramount
that's the fundamental philosophy that
drove the soviet union in maoist china
and it's the fundamental philosophy of
the left-wing activists its identity
politics doesn't matter who you are as
an individual it matters who you are in
terms of your group identity you're just
saying
so to
you want to stir things up i'm only a
provocateur in so far as when i say what
i believe to be true it's provocative i
don't provoke
maybe for you
now and then i'm not interested in
provoking but what about the thing about
you know
fighting and the lobster tell us about
the lobster
well that's quite a segway oh the
lobster was in his book
what is the lobster
um so
he talks about like the nervous systems
and lobsters and hierarchies and lobster
communities and compares it to
humans because we have a common ancestor
like they're a common ancestor basically
like eve here
well the first chapter i have in my book
is called stand up straight with your
shoulders back and it's an injunction to
be combative
not least to further your career let's
say
but also to adopt
a stance of ready engagement with the
world and to reflect that in your
posture and the reason that i
write about lobsters is because there's
this idea that hierarchical structures
are a
sociological construct of the western
patriarchy and that is so untrue that
it's almost unbelievable and i use the
lobster as an example because the
lobster we we
divulged from lobsters in evolutionary
history about 350 million years ago
common ancestor and lobsters exist in
hierarchies and they have a nervous
system attuned to the hierarchy and that
nervous system runs on serotonin just
like our nervous systems do and the
nervous system of the lobster and the
human being is so similar that
antidepressants work on lobsters and
it's part of my attempt to demonstrate
that the idea of hierarchy has
absolutely nothing to do with
sociocultural construction which it
doesn't let me just get straight you're
saying that we should organize our
societies
along the lines of the lobsters
i'm saying that it's inevitable that
there will be continuity in the way that
animals and human beings organize
organize their structures it's it's
absolutely inevitable and there is
one-third of a billion years of
evolutionary history behind that right
that's that's so long that a third of a
billion years ago there weren't even
trees
it's a long time you have a mechanism in
your brain that runs on serotonin that's
similar to the lobster mechanism that
tracks your status
and the higher your status the better
your emotions are regulated so as your
serotonin levels increase you feel more
positive emotion and less negative
emotion so you're saying like the
lobsters we're hardwired as men and
women to do certain things to sort of
run along tram lines and there's nothing
we can do about it no i'm not saying
there's nothing we can do about it
because it's like a in a chess game
right there's lots of things that you
can do although you can't break the
rules of the chess game and continue to
play chess biological your your
biological nature is somewhat like that
is it sets the rules of the game but
within those rules you have a lot of
leeway but the idea that but
one thing we can't do is say that
hierarchical organization is a
consequence of the capitalist patriarchy
it's like that's patently absurd it's
wrong it's not a matter of opinion it's
seriously wrong
aren't you just whipping people up into
a state of anger
divisions between men and women you're
stirring people up you know
any critics of you
[Laughter]
i love him like he's like he's funny but
i don't i do to certain things he is
like trying to be funny but i i think
he's just like being himself
the patriarchy thing like so he's
basically saying like even lobster
communities have a hierarchy
yeah
this guy is funny like
it's it's it's what is funny about him
is
his his mannerisms and his responses
and it's just because of
the the faces that he makes
and he's so much smarter than everyone
else like i just feel like you don't
think so
[Laughter]
[Music]
generally
sorry your critics get lambasted by you
i mean if they're irresponsible not at
all if an academic is going to come
after me and tell me that i'm not
qualified and that i'm not i don't know
what i'm talking about so you're not
going to say your followers now quit the
abuse quit the anger
well we'd need some
substantial examples of the abuse and
the anger before i could detail that
question there's a lot of output for
well let's take a more general
perspective on that so i've had 25 000
letters since june something like that
from people who told me that i brought
them back from the brink of destruction
and so i'm perfectly willing to put that
up against the rather vague accusations
that my followers are making the lives
of people that i've targeted miserable
jordan peterson thank you
my pleasure nice talking with you
he
he i was one of those people i didn't
write him a letter but he convinced me
to stop drinking which made my life a
lot better
what'd you think of them
i i liked it it's just we have to take
our feelings out and it's very
unfortunate um
like
it's just how i was saying these things
can't actually be practiced yeah
because there's no way to regulate them
um
but i guess
ladies and gents just take into account
the factors that could contribute to
your unequal pay and stand up for
yourself
wow
that's
my goosebumps
i don't know for real because
like it's interesting it changed your
perspective a little bit right is this
this because you know it's it's just a
different way of thinking like i'm gonna
walk out the door like this
no i started out jordan peterson did
this to me i swear to god i used to
think like you with the just like the
disparities in pay and stuff i used to
think the same way
but like he just makes points
i i'm a person in life i think no matter
the circumstance you should um
be willing if you want to change your
life or to grow in any kind of way
to take your feelings out of things and
look um
from another perspective
and see
what could contribute to that and so
that makes sense saying
you know take account the factors of why
that someone might be getting different
you may not like it
but at least you can think
ladies and gentlemen okay this is what
we do this is what we do
on um the just pearly things channel so
guys guys
like the video okay like the video
subscribe to the channel um and
subscribe to her channel too let's get
her to a thousand subs so we can get her
monetized too yeah if you're not if
you're not subscribing or liking any of
our videos we have b
b
okay guys um
like the video subscribe we'll talk to
you guys next time bye